High School boys are trending
conservative 12th grade boys are nearly
twice as likely to identify as
conservative versus liberal according to
a respected Federal survey of American
Youth young men and boys are trending
conservative and when you when you
narrow it down to 12th grade boys there
are twice as likely to identify as
conservative versus liberal which is a
striking difference from the past as
they point out now a few reasons why
teenage boys and young men are
increasingly becoming conservative and
the first is that conservatism is
rebellious okay it's edgy it's uh
offensive in our culture by our culture
standards it's the rebellious edgy
offensive thing and if you have that
kind of renegade Instinct that desire to
Rebel as many young people do especially
boys then this is where you go